[Musique]
comment va jo elle ne décroche pas un
mot je veux pas tu as pitié en plus de
jeunes
cette pouliche mauvais fonden elle est
en colère c'est tout elle a été capturée
et arraché à sa famille elle s'appelle
comment
je lui ai pas encore donné non toi aussi
tu as perdu ta famille tu es vraiment
magnifique
je crois que j'ai trouvé ton nom black
beauty et soe
[Musique]
en quelques jours tu as réussi là où
j'avais échoué depuis des semaines on
dit que ce sont les chevaux qui nous
choisissent merci piety le temps qu'on
consacre aux chevaux sauvages est
limitée ici vous pouvez pas vendre duty
tu fais ma famille
tu sais que tu ma famille
[Musique]
jusqu'à retrouverez j'te trop mais là
elle m'a sauvé tu sais comment un cheval
peut sauver une personne
[Musique]
si j'avais dû me battre pour tous les
chevaux que j'ai aimé un jour j'en aurai
plus d'une centaine
j'en veux pas une centaine
j'en veux qu'un seul
et
[Musique]